moi ce que j'aime avec christian jacob
oui la nouvelle génération des
républicains c'est que oui il est des
hommes et des femmes aujourd'hui en
politique qui attend l'équipe réunir
leurs convictions leur écrire mais c'est
un homme de conviction girex j'ai
répondu très clairement dès vendredi
soit j'ai écouté jean castex
oui mon confrère wild tf1 oui les mots
qu'il a utilisée furent juste l'écologie
n'est pas une option
oui je ne dois pas décidé depuis paris
la laïcité est un où elle tente très
bien mais qui croire
les mots justes de jean castex nommer ou
le bilan cataclysmique d' emmanuel
macron qui conduit hélas on l'a bien vu
et détermine la politique de la nation
la question on l'a bien compris ces
derniers mois d'ailleurs n'est pas tel
ou tel premier ministre la question
c'est la politique menée par le
président de la république
le problème dans notre pays c'est
emmanuel macron et son bilan désastreux
et les fautes immense du maquereau nisme
ne seront pas dissoute par un
remaniement quelques fûts son ampleur il
faut dire ce que nous voyons il faut
dire ce que les français voient un bilan
cataclysmique 2700 milliards d'euros de
dette
mille milliards d'euros d'impôts de
taxes et de charges qui pèsent chaque
année sur nos compatriotes un record en
matière d'immigration 276000 titre de
séjour accordés en 2019 des territoires
qui n'en peuvent plus nous sommes nous
en loir et cher comme partout dans les
provinces démunis face au manque de
médecins
face à la question du numérique le bilan
des manuels macron est un bilan
exécrable et c'est pas en changeant de
premier ministre en dans l'ue millions
déjà d'ailleurs ce matin puisqu'il
annonce rendez vous compte
méprisant l'article 20 de la
constitution que le premier ministre
verra son discours de politique générale
repoussé aux calendes grecques du mois
de juillet et que c'est lui
emmanuel macron qui va déterminer et
conduire la politique de la nation en
s'adressant de nos compatriotes le 14
juillet les français attendent qu'on
réhabilite en france la valeur du
travail qu'on récompense ceux qui
bossent parce que la france saura
redresser par ceux qui se lèvent tôt
parle l'héroïsme des humbles
par les caissiers par les ouvriers par
les employés par les entrepreneurs par
les artisans par les agriculteurs par
toute cette france là qu'on ne voit
jamais il faut redonner le le sens des
valeurs du respect du respect qu'on doit
à l'autre du respect qu'on doit à nos
forces de l'ordre du respect que l'on
doit à notre drapeau